und wir schauen jetzt zur
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
in die staatskanzlei in mainz schönen
guten tag frau dreyer
ich grüße sie auch sehr herzlich von
drei sie kommen sozusagen gerade aus der
telefonschalte mit der kanzlerin und den
weiteren ministerpräsidenten die
kanzlerin hat dort einen wichtigen satz
gesagt sie hat gesagt pandemie kennt
keine feiertage dürfen die menschen
jetzt nicht mehr ostern feiern
na ja sie dürfen natürlich ostern feiern
aber sie sollten nach wie vor einfach
jegliche zusätzliche soziale kontakte
vermeiden
das bedeutet sie sollten keine oster
reisen machen wir sollen nicht familien
besuchen gehen sondern sie sollen in den
kleinen kreis in dem sie eben sind auch
einfach bleiben und ostern mal so ganz
ganz anders feiern leider ist die lage
so wie sie ist sie soll vor allem nicht
ihre großeltern eltern besuchen fahren
weil das alles müssen wir vermeiden um
gerade die ältere generation und auch
management vor belastungen tatsächlich
zu schützen und dieses gebot geht
weiterhin leider auch an ostern
erzählen sie uns etwas aus dieser
telefonschalte wie dramatisch war dort
das bild dass kanzlerin merkel
gezeichnet hat na ja wir sind ja alle
als regierungschefin chefin tagtäglich
mit dem thema kohona intensiv befasst
und deshalb ist dieser austausch uns
alle auch sehr wichtig weil wir uns zum
ziel genommen haben dass wir
deutschlandweit agieren wollen wenn
immer es möglich ist und deshalb sind
auch diese abstimmung sehr wichtig wir
waren alle einer meinung dass es nicht
genug tendenzen im moment gibt das den
anstieg der des
das virus betrifft dass man sagen kann
wir wir können jetzt irgendwie auch für
uns sein wir müssen weitermachen wir
müssen weiter respektiv bleiben und der
appell heute ist wirklich auch genau auf
ostern gerichtet weil wir üblicherweise
user ganz anders feiern und ich glaube
auch bei schönen wetter die lust der
begegnung steigen wird deshalb so
wichtig ist nochmal zu betonen von uns
also an alle regierungschefs und
chefinnen es ist nicht die zeit das wir
jetzt lachs werden sind wir müssen uns
strecken an die maßgaben halten die wir
die ganze zeit ja auch durch das wird
haben wenn sie die zahlen sehen und sie
stehen ja auch in ihrem bundesland mit
den ärzten in kontakt mit den
krankenhäusern wie schlimm wird es wie
sehen sie die situation
ich sehe die situation dass sie nach wie
vor sehr angespannt ist dass ich jetzt
in den letzten ein zwei tagen es sich
etwas eingependelt aber es lange nicht
so ist dass man aus dieser tendenz
irgendwie eine längerfristige konsequenz
ziehen könnte sondern dass wir gehalten
sind diese maßnahmen die wir ergriffen
haben dass wir sie weiter durchführen
wir haben eine große verpflichtung
verantwortung für unsere ältere
generation und auch für menschen die
eine vorerkrankung haben und ich möchte
auch noch mal sagen dann falls liegt an
der grenze zu frankreich wir erleben
würde ich diese furchtbare situation im
elsass wir haben viele freunde auch in
italien wir sehen was in diesen ländern
gerade stattfindet und wir müssen alles
daran setzen weiterhin durch eine
reduktion sozialer kontakte dass wir
besser gerüstet sind und dass uns eben
einer solchen welle nicht so erfasst
dass wir wirklich die chance haben mit
diesem virus umzugehen und das ist und
bleibt eine ganz große herausforderung
für uns alle
sie sprechen von der virus welle
gleichzeitig droht auch eine pleitewelle
das heißt die insbesondere die
wirtschaft macht druck und sagt wir
müssen natürlich darüber sprechen wie
wir da wieder rauskommen
welche hoffnung können sie denn machen
wann wird es denn wieder normaler in
deutschland wir können kein datum in der
zukunft setzen sei ausgeschlossen
versteh das ist ganz ganz viele
unternehmer und unternehmerinnen
wirklich ernsthafte sorgen machen aber
ich möchte auch noch einmal sagen es ist
nicht nur so dass wir wie viel geld
milliarden und ganz viel manpower
organisieren wenn wir das
gesundheitssystem funktioniert sondern
wir investieren auch einmalig beträge in
unser wirtschaftssystem um betriebe
unternehmen die betroffen sind auch
selbstständige ihnen wirklich eine
unterstützung zu geben dass sie wirklich
liquiditätssorgen überbrücken können das
tut der staat ist die bundesregierung
erste landesregierungen und wir sind da
wirklich auch sehr eng miteinander weil
wir die notes 10 nichtsdestotrotz ist
dennoch der gesundheitsschutz der
bevölkerung geht vor
wir sehen mich wäre das ist für die
wirtschaft wir tun alles um es ab zu mir
und wir müssen einfach ein bisschen noch
auf sicht fahren bis klar ist dass wir
wirklich es erreichen dass die
infektions würfel dauerhaft wirklich
auch nach unten geht
wie sieht es in ihrem bundesland aus
wenn wir darüber sprechen dass es
mittlerweile debatten gibt das für
möglicherweise umschwenken sollten aus
der alten tradition in einer art notfall
wirtschaft und dann masken und
beatmungsgeräte produzieren sollen wie
sehen sie das ist das möglich in
deutschland und muss so umgesteuert
werden
ich glaube da ist mir einiges aus dieser
krise werden lernen können und natürlich
dass wir so eine hohe abhängigkeit weiß
sehr wichtigen produkten haben gegen
medizinbetrieb so unbedingt erforderlich
sind das ist sicherlich eine frage mit
der man sich beschäftigen wird im moment
ist es so andernfalls dass wir
eigentlich ganz viel engagierte wirklich
auch sehr konstruktiv mitwirken wie hier
haben
und natürlich gibt es auch debatten um
die beschaffung auch wir sind angewiesen
auf märkte im ausland und wir haben auch
viele die im bereich der textilindustrie
momente am überlegen sind können wir
auch etwas tun aber da geht es wird
sich nicht um die medizinischen
schutzmasken da ist dieses know how
nicht in unserem bundesland zurzeit oder
es geht tatsächlich darum dass man auch
ja zum fremdschutz diese community
masken vielleicht auch mitproduziert ich
bin sehr froh dass wir zwei hersteller
haben die beatmungsgeräte im produzieren
das ist ja wirklich auch eine ganze
technologie die wirklich sinnvoll das
produzieren und ihre kapazitäten auch
ausgeweitet haben auch beatmungsgeräte
brauchen wir zunehmend mehr und deshalb
bin ich froh darüber sagen zu können
dass wir das in unserem land haben aber
ganz sicher wird uns diese frage was die
schutzausrüstung mit für die medizin
dieselbe debatte haben wir beim thema
medikamente wie stark müssen wir uns da
auch vielleicht noch ein stück neu
orientieren
gehen sie davon aus dass es zu
katastrophalen zuständen in kliniken in
krankenhäusern in deutschland auch
kommen wird so wie in italien
meine aufgabe als regierungschefin ist
alles daran zu setzen dass wir nicht in
solche schwierige laden kommen sondern
alles wirklich alles zu tun was in
unserer macht steht um möglichst viele
menschen zu schützen vor dieser
infektion und umgekehrt auch unser
gesundheitssystem weiter zu entwickeln
so dass wir gut gerüstet sind und ich
sehe wie stark sie intensiv kapazitäten
in allen krankenhäusern auch
hochgefahren werden das ist bundesweiter
fall und da bleiben wir wirklich mit
großer kraft auch dahinter vor der zum
abschluss eine persönliche frage wie
gehen sie persönlich damit um mit diesem
virus wie schützen sie sich und wie
fürsorge und angst haben sie dass sie
sich oder auch ihre engste familienkreis
sich damit infizieren könnte also ich
bin wirklich sehr sehr konsequent wir
haben schon sehr früh damit begonnen
auch beispielsweise hier in der
staatskanzlei die gruppen zu trennen so
dass menschen die an schlüsselpositionen
sind ich nicht begegnen sich nicht
persönlich treffen wir haben eigentlich
die komplette kommunikation inzwischen
über tele schalten oder über telefon
schaltkonferenz unorganisiert ich selber
halte mich auch mit sozialen kontakten
total
ich bin im grunde wird sich auch im
engsten familienkreis zusammen
und natürlich geht es mir wie jedem
anderen menschen in unserer gesellschaft
auch wenn ich mir immer auch sorgen
machen um meine liebsten und einfach nur
hoffe das ist konsequente handeln dazu
führen dass niemand von uns erkrankt
herzlichen dank für das gespräch und
bleiben sie gesund dann gegen abend
laden sie auch gesund
dankeschön